aquí tenemos arturo y aquí tenemos al
tío de arturo y arturo está en un
pequeño problema no sólo no tiene dinero
sino que le debe dinero a su amiga
mariana que no está aquí le debe a
mariana tres pesos así que su valor neto
de menos tres pesos y al tío de arturo
que se preocupa mucho por él y se siente
mal de que esté en esta situación de que
ni siquiera tenga valor neto cero sino
que sea tenga valor neto negativo
decidió ayudarlo decide quitarle este
peso encima quiere ayudarlo a regresar a
cero así que decide decide quitarle este
valor neto negativo así que decide
quitarle estos menos tres pesos de valor
neto pero qué pasa si se los quitan
entonces arturo debería regresar a cero
debería tener valor neto cero si tienes
cualquier cosa y la quitas debería
regresar a cero si le debes dinero a
alguien y lo pagas entonces deberías
regresar a cero y otro modo de pensar en
esto es cómo le va a ser el tío de
arturo para ayudar a arturo cómo lo va a
hacer para quitarle esta deuda pues el
modo más sencillo hacerlo
que su tío le de arturo tres pesos
tiene tres pesos y entonces arturo
regresaría a cero y ojalá ojalá esto dé
una idea de por qué estas dos cosas
deben ser intuitivamente equivalentes